it is
finally here
after a long wait the 32nd olympic games
are actually happening this summer
but tokyo 2020 will be unlike any games
we've seen before
here's why
tokyo 2020 was postponed and rescheduled
because of the covet 19 pandemic
the postponement has cost an estimated
2.5
billion pounds
the olympic games have never been
postponed or cancelled for anything
apart from war with the 1916
1940 and 1944 games
all being called off because of the
first and second world wars
obviously the biggest changes are all to
do with covet 19.
no spectators will be allowed to watch
the events in the tokyo stadiums
following a surge in cases of the delta
variant
japan has declared a coronavirus state
of emergency for the capital
that will run throughout the event that
means public viewings of the games
have been cancelled restaurants and bars
will even be asked to stop
serving alcohol
[Music]
in short a lot
international competitors will be tested
before departure
and as they arrive in the country while
in japan
they need to stay in their bubbles and
not mix with locals
they will then be regularly tested for
kobit
[Music]
the iconic olympic torch relay has
already been drastically affected
by the coveted walls
it's been diverted from busy areas with
multiple athletes pulling out
over fears about drawing crowds that
could help spread the pandemic
[Music]
putting the pandemic to one side for a
moment there are some exciting changes
coming to
tokyo 2020 we have five new sports
surfing skateboarding baseball softball
karate and sports climbing the games
will also see
skateboarder sky brown become britain's
youngest summer olympian
she'll be 13 years and 11 days old
when she competes in tokyo it means
the world to me i mean i it's gonna be
really fun
and i'm excited to represent tinkerine
[Applause]
[Music]
team gb is sending its largest team ever
for an overseas olympics
for the first time in history there are
more female
the male athletes competing
it will be a time where there will be
more females on the tv at any one time
than you'll ever see
and i just think that is such um a
brilliant thing for the younger
generation coming through
tokyo 2020 will also see the first
transgender athlete competing
laurel hubbard was selected for new
zealand's weightlifting team
after meeting all the requirements set
out by the ioc
for trans athletes
tokyo 2020 has become a controversial
subject across the country
according to the nikkei newspaper 63
of the japanese public are opposed to
holding the games
critics say bringing an estimated 90 000
athletes
officials journalists and other workers
into japan
isn't the best idea in a pandemic
japan has handled the coronavirus better
than most
but some fear this could be unravelled
by hosting the games
but all the complaints and protests have
not changed the organizers minds
with one senior olympic official saying
the only thing that will stop these
games
is armageddon